as the top federal prosecutor in
Manhattan Jeffrey Berman has led several
investigations into corruption close to
the US presidents in a circle today we
unseal an indictment charging Lev Parnas
Igor Froman in October last year he
announced charges against two men linked
to Donald Trump's personal lawyer Rudy
Giuliani they were accused of trying to
buy influence of a US policy in Ukraine
in a case that added fuel to the calls
for Trump's impeachment they sought
political influence not only to advance
their own financial interests but to
advance the political interests of at
least one foreign official these cases
and an investigation into Giuliani have
concerned the Trump administration on
Friday night Attorney General William
Bar announced Berman was leaving his
position saying that the president
intends to nominate Jay Clayton the
current chairman of the Securities and
Exchange Commission a lawyer with no
experience as a prosecutor bar statement
ending by thanking Jeffrey Berman
describing him as stepping down after
two and a half years of service the only
problem is Jeffrey Berman says he's not
going anywhere releasing his own
statement I learned an a press release
from the Attorney General tonight that I
was stepping down as United States
Attorney
I have not resigned and have no
intention of resigning my position the
Trump administration has a growing
reputation for forcing out anyone seen
as disloyal in recent weeks the
president has fired a number of agency
watchdogs including the Inspector
General of the intelligence community
whose actions led to the impeachment
inquiry Barr offered no explanation for
attempting to replace Berman a
Republican who once donated to Trump's
campaign Democrats have accused Barr of
politicizing the Department of Justice
and acting more like Trump's personal
lawyer the boundaries of notions of
separations of powers and checks and
balances and undermining its credibility
I think quite significantly by doing
Trump's or the bidding for Senate
Democrat Chuck Schumer of New York has
tweeted the dismissal reeks of potential
corruption of the legal process
questioning what action by Berman had
motivated the president Berman's led
cases against Trump's former personal
lawyer Michael Cohen and convicted sex
offender Jeffrey Epstein
he says he'll continue to pursue justice
without fear or favor until a
presidentially appointed replacement is
confirmed by the Senate alexia Bryan
al-jazeera